mal y despertó con la dimisión forzada
de su presidente e ibragim bubacar keita
la disolución de la asamblea nacional
no deseo que se derrame sangre para
mantenerme en el poder muy bien después
del golpe de estado orquestado por el
ejército maliense durante el martes y el
arresto del mandatario en el poder desde
2013 los militares bajo el
autodenominado comité nacional para la
salvación del pueblo prometieron
realizar elecciones en un tiempo
razonable y actuar para evitar más caos
anarquía e inseguridad
y malienses no nos interesa el poder
pero si la estabilidad del país lo que
nos permitirá organizar en un plazo
razonable elecciones generales que le
permitan a mali dotarse de instituciones
fuertes capaces de gestionar nuestra
vida cotidiana y restablecer la
confianza entre el gobierno y el pueblo
quien fue visto como una figura de
unidad en un país fracturado por la
violencia yihadista keita fue incapaz de
cumplir su promesa de unir a la nación y
solventar sus crisis en las calles de
bamako cientos de ciudadanos celebraron
su caída del poder
no no nos esperábamos esto en absoluto
fue una sorpresa pero en cualquier caso
la población había abandonado al
presidente necesitábamos que los
militares intervinieron para poner fin a
lo que estaba pasando
ante el temor de que la renuncia del
mandatario pueda desestabilizar toda la
región del sahel en áfrica occidental la
comunidad internacional condenó el acto
y la unión africana suspendió la
membresía de mal